Karl Lauterbach der sendet 24 Stunden
überall seit zwei Jahren in der
corona-krise er spricht erklärt das ist
gut aber zu oft sagt er heute das und
morgen dann leider was anderes jetzt
sorgt dieser Fernsehauftritt von Karl
Lauterbach bei Markus Lanz für heftige
Kritik wegen Lauterbachs Behauptung auch
die Ergebnisse von Corona Schnelltests
würden in die offizielle Statistik
einfließen
also wenn er anders Gesundheitsamt
gemeldet wird zählt natürlich auch der
antige intest
ja also das müssen wir unter die Lupe
nehmen Lauterbach sagt da in dem ganz
kurzen Ausschnitt dass auch
schnelltestergebnisse in die offizielle
corona-statistik einfließen was stimmt
was nicht bildpolitikchef Jan Schäfer
haben beim RKI gestern nachgefragt
besser gesagt der Kollege philipp
piathoff hat gestern nachgefragt und hat
die Antwort vom RKI bekommen nein die
Aussage von Karl Lauterbach ist falsch
also wirklich nur
PCR-Tests fließen ein in die Statistik
also offenbar hat er sich da Geir aber
wie kann man dann überhaupt darauf wie
kann man auf den Gedanken dass auch die
Schnelltests mit einfließen wir hören
aus der Regierung dass es Überlegungen
gibt weil wir bei PCR-Tests ja Probleme
sehen was die Verteilung angeht dass man
künftig möglicherweise auch diese
Schnelltests mit einbeziehen möchte das
wird aber gerade noch diskutiert dazu
gibt es noch gar keinen festen Stand und
möglicherweise hat Karl Lauterbach das
einfach schon vorausgenommen einmal mehr
und hat so proklamiert als wenn es diese
diesen Faktum schon geben würde tut es
aber lass nur einmal reinschauen in den
kurzen Ausschnitt von Marco und Markus
Lanz
eine boosterimpfung für alle wäre jetzt
auf keinen Fall sinnvoll wir haben zum
einen keinen medizinischen Grund den
Booster für alle jetzt anzubieten weil
die Impfung für die unter
65/70-jährigen noch wirksam ist sehr gut
wirksam ist
greifen wir auch Vorausbildung über den
wir reden müssen bildpolitikgeschäft Jan
Schäfer das Lauterbach hin und her denn
auch das hat Karl Lauterbach in dieser
Krise gesagt das Boostern wird hier
nicht für jeden nötig sein und wenig
später hat er das gesagt
es ist klar es hat ein paar Monaten dass
wir halt jeden Erwachsenen Boostern
müssen seit ein paar Monaten ein Monaten
ist das klar das ist klar und das haben
wir so Spezialisten auch also relativ
früh gesagt
dann ist ja dann ist Argumente dann ist
also zunächst einmal ausgerechnet worden
können wir das dann schaffen durch die
niedergelassenen Kollegen allein lauter
ja lauter nein mal so mal so heute so
morgen so ist das ganz normal in dieser
corona-krise in der ja man immer von
neuen Herausforderungen steht oder ist
das auch ein bisschen ein
lauterbachphänomen das ein Lauterbach
Phänomen uns ist es zum einen lauter ja
lauter nein aber ist auch lauter hin
lauter her denn das was wir gerade
gesehen haben ist natürlich
maximal auch sozusagen Wasser auf die
Bühne derjenigen die ohnehin mit der
Politik unzufrieden sind wir sehen es
bei Karl Lauterbach immer wieder dass er
sich korrigieren muss er ist auch so
etwas wie ein nicht nur
Gesundheitsminister sondern auch
horror-prognosenminister wir haben es
vor Weihnachten gesehen wir haben
letztes Jahr vor Ostern gesehen dass er
wirkliche Horror Prognosen was
beispielsweise die Zahl der Infizierten
angeht oder die Belegung von
Intensivbetten an die Wand malt am Ende
stellen wir fest deutlich unter der
Latte durch zum Glück muss man sagen
aber diese Horror Prognosen sind nie in
Kraft getreten oder sind überhaupt die
haben sich nie bewahrheitet und von
daher muss man sagen das was er dort
macht dieses Hin und Her auf der einen
Seite einmal Boostern eher nicht und
dann doch auf jeden Fall wieder oder
auch die anderen Prognosen mit denen er
auch immer wieder die Öffentlichkeit
schockt die tragen nicht dazu bei dass
die Glaubwürdigkeit in die Politik
steigt die Impfpflicht das ist gerade
das Thema das ganz ganz viele Menschen
hier in Deutschland wirklich aufreibt
und da tut sich ja auch die
Bundesregierung sehr sehr schwer einmal
Höhe einmal Hopp man weiß nicht genau
wie man das umsetzen kann fakt ist sie
ist nicht da in Österreich gegen sie
gestern durch und hier fragen sich viele
Menschen noch was passiert jetzt
überhaupt damit auch dazu gibt es ein
Statement von Karl Lauterbach das
eventuell mehr Fragen als Antworten
geben könnte
ich glaube dass also Ärzte jeden impfen
sollten denjenigen der geimpft werden
will weil er der Impfpflicht nachkommt
oder denjenigen der sich impfen lässt
ganz freiwillig es wird ja niemand gegen
seinen Willen geimpft selbst die
Impfpflicht führte dazu dass man sich
zum Schluss freiwillig impfen lässt die
Impfpflicht die dazu führt dass man sich
am Ende freiwillig impfen lässt Jan das
klingt ein bisschen wie ein Hohn also
man könnte fast sagen Deutsch Karl
Lauterbach Karl Lauterbach Deutsch man
muss das vielleicht übersetzen mein
Eindruck ist was er damit sagen wollte
dass wenn diese Impfpflicht kommt dass
das den Druck erhöht sich impfen zu
lassen das ist ja auch der Sinn aber
Kern ist natürlich wir haben es beim
Thema Impfpflicht mit ganz ganz vielen
Nebelgranaten zu tun auch vom
Bundesgesundheitsminister selbst aber
auch der Bundeskanzler und viele andere
Ministerpräsidenten die seit Wochen seit
Monaten dafür Trommeln sind uns
eigentlich bisher die Erklärung schuldig
geblieben wie genau diese Impfpflicht
umgesetzt werden
Karl Lauterbach trägt jetzt mit diesem
Statement einmal mehr zur Verunsicherung
bei also es ist ein Tollhaus was wir
sehen in Sachen Impfpflicht die man weiß
wie es umgesetzt werden soll und
offenbar widerspricht sich der Minister
in gewisser Weise auch selbst
Impfpflicht bedeutet ja dass ich jeder
zwangsweise impfen müsste und er
referiert ja auf einer Aussage des
kassenärztepräsidenten Gassen der gesagt
hat die Ärzte wollen in ihren Praxen
dann nicht zwangsweise impfen also
Tollhaus Impfpflicht wir hoffen dass wir
nächste Woche ein bisschen mehr Klarheit
haben aber klar ist die Regierung ist in
der Pflicht und es ist erstaunlich das
bisher noch niemand sagen kann wie
dieser Weg zur Impfpflicht eigentlich
aussehen soll wie erklärst du dir dass
es so viel Lauterbach ja Nein hin und
her gibt das ist so viel Verwirrung
letztendlich auch stiften kann bei ganz
vielen Menschen hat uns ja selbst auch
mal im Interview verraten wie sehr er
sich mit Studien beschäftigt dass er bis
tief in die Nacht rein liest um jede
Studie die auch aus dem USA frisch kommt
noch irgendwie in sein Wissen
aufzufassen wie erklärst du dir dann
dass es oft so Zickzack geht
ich glaube was wir in der Pandemie sehen
ist natürlich das gewisse Dinge die man
vorausgesagt hat für ein oder zwei
Monate sich manchmal auch anders
entwickeln und anders ergeben und
insofern ist es sicherlich auch in
Ordnung dass ich der ein oder andere
korrigiert ich glaube es ist bloß
wichtig dass man das dann auch ganz klar
sagt und sagt okay hier habe ich mich
geirrt hier lag ich falsch das sind
Dinge die man von Karl Lauterbach aber
bisher nicht hört und ich glaube das
trägt zur Ehrlichkeit da nicht gerade
bei also es wäre gut wenn ein Minister
der auch gefühlt schon ganz ganz lange
ja Bundesgesundheitsminister ist am Ende
auch mal sagt hier lag ich falsch
Korrektur so muss es richtig sein das
ist interessant weil gerade der
Expertenrat der Bundesregierung das ja
immer jetzt in seine Papiere schreibt
dass man klar kommunizieren möchte mit
uns mit allen Bürgern und Bürgerinnen in
Deutschland in dieser so schwierigen
corona-krise Bild Politik schlecht Jan
Schäfer über den Lauterbach Zickzack den
lauter hin und her wie er sagt vielen
Dank ja und wir
müssen Klarheit in Sachen coronazahlen
schauen rauf hier auf unseren großen
Monitor mit den aktuellen
Infektionszahlen und von dieser Kurve
hier gibt es aktuell noch keine gute
Nachrichten die steigt und steigt wir
testen und testen und testen und Omicron
verbreitet sich weiter rasant in
Deutschland das heißt wir haben aktuell
neue Höchstwerte wieder bei den
Infektionszahlen über 140.000 und diese
Zahl darauf können wir uns jetzt schon
einstellen die wird in den nächsten
Tagen und Wochen weiter erstmal steigen
bevor und das ist dann wiederum die ganz
gute Nachricht erwartet wird dass sie
dann rasant wieder abreißt das haben
andere Länder ja vorgemacht zunächst
Südafrika mittlerweile auch
Großbritannien und andere Länder die uns
eben voraus sind aber wir haben eine
ganz gute Nachricht hier auf dieser
Karte auch die Zahl der Todesfälle immer
noch natürlich zu hoch aber sie singt
seit einigen Tagen wir haben jetzt 170
Todesfälle in Deutschland mit Corona in
den vergangenen 24 Stunden also diese
Kurve singt und im Vergleich dieser
beiden Kurven sehen Sie jetzt schon die
Infektionszahlen breiten sich aus die
Todesfälle sinken aktuell das heißt hier
steckt schon drin das Omicron offenbar
eben weniger tödlich weniger gefährlich
für uns ist wir schauen auf die Hotspots
aktuell in Deutschland wir sehen eine
rote Karte die uns so aktuell aber nicht
mehr allzu sehr Schrecken mag wir sehen
neuerdings eben Hotspots hier auch im
Norden in Brandenburg in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern in Hamburg und
Schleswig-Holstein Gebiete die bis vor
zwei Wochen noch komplett grün waren
aber was sind dann die Auswirkungen in
den Krankenhäusern darauf kommt es an
und diese Karte ist nicht rot aktuell
sie kennen diese Schwellenwerte von der
hospitalisierungsinsidenz 36 und 9 der
Warenwert sozusagen und den erreichen
wir aktuell in Deutschland nirgendwo
außer in Bremen etwas brisanter die Lage
auch hier jetzt ausgerechnet im Norden
in Schleswig wo es so lange entspannt
war in Bundesländern in denen die
Impfquoten interessanterweise sehr hoch
sind in Bremen ist die Impfquote die
höchste da haben wir aber gleichzeitig
die höchste Belastung in den
Krankenhäusern und dann zum Vergleich
ausgerechnet hier in Sachsen wo die
Impfquote geringer ist da haben wir
aktuell die niedrigsten Inzidenzen und
die niedrigste
hospitalisierungsinzidenz das also die
Wahrheit über die krankenhausbelegung
aktuell in dieser corona-krise keine
entspannte Situation aber bei weitem
keine so dramatische Lage wie etwa zwei
Wochen vor Weihnachten Patricia